what's your top three i can't say soda
pops though why could you only say pop
over there yeah [ __ ] saying pop pop is
such a like an underwhelming word
soda is the word in oregon you don't say
soda
it's called a pot yeah exactly when i
moved to oregon i went
shut the [ __ ] up
just say [ __ ] soda
or don't criticize me when you mean pop
no i meant soda [ __ ] does it say pop on
the thing no it says [ __ ] coca-cola
so we're both wrong [ __ ] you
i know it's trashy to [ __ ] call it
pop it's not trashy
it's just what people say that's a
little trash it's on the west coast
there's no little spots in the [ __ ]
country soda is the more sophisticated
word yeah no it's like saying like use
ain't it i say use when i'm talking [ __ ]
to people yeah use a [ __ ] i'm talking
about a normal conversation that's i'll
judge a [ __ ] if you use use
guys
i'll judge you listen dr pepper is the
supreme soda i'm just gonna say that
there we're going yeah top three okay
thank you